[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
he's our fortress
[Music]
i can feel you pulling things around in
there it's a brand new organ
never before seen
[Music]
we've all felt that the body was empty
empty of meaning
we've wanted to confirm that
so that we could fill it with meaning
[Music]
the world is a much more dangerous place
now that pain has all but disappeared
[Music]
surgery is sex isn't it
is it
you know it is
surrey is the new sex
[Music]
i don't like what's happening with the
body
in particular what's happening with my
body
[Music]
which is why i keep cutting it up
[Music]
sorry
let us not be afraid to map the chaos
inside
[Music]
let us create a map
that will guide us
into the heart of darkness
[Music]
hello there now i know what you're
thinking crikey a black cat he's gonna
bring me bad luck
shows what you know about luck
let's drop some knowledge
luck is different all around the world
like in scotland where a black cat like
me is considered very lucky remember
kids don't try this at home
name's bob by the way and this is the
land of luck
morning jerry we work behind the scenes
to create those wee lucky and unlucky
moments that make up your everyday life
like these guys an entire team thinking
up the jammy luck that kind that makes
you feel like a million bucks
okay maybe a hundred bucks of course
then there's the other team
working on the not so jammy kind of luck
and they sure love what they do
well you humans are a complicated lot
and that's why things run so smoothly
here because no human has ever stepped
foot in this place and with a little bit
of luck they never will
uh
where am i
oh you gotta be kidding
[Music]
this suit means something
it's not just protecting your body it's
protecting the universe ready captain
lightyear ready as i'll ever be to
infinity and
we've got a breach in the privilege
thank you
let's get everyone home
oh no
let's light your mission log my mistake
has marooned us on this strange planet
i need to make it right
hello buzz i am socks my mission is to
help you and i'm not giving up on my
mission i'm not giving up either great
would you like a frosted snack kick to
celebrate negative
was like your mission log i plan to
finally finish the mission oh you're
talking to buzz no no one
here we go
are we going to crash no
well technically yes
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
what is going on
the what i hope you're ready for action
because all we needed was a pilot for
what you have to destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team do you
have munitions partial so you're rookies
oh boy we'd love to be rookies
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it
people people people let's go
did you hear that i don't hear anything
oh now i do
do this grab it it's the violation of my
parole
i think i need a bed no no engage your
helmet that'll catch it
let's go finish the mission
we're being
pursued just a massive robot
we can do anything you're not shouting
my ear oh yeah
[Music]
hey what's that noise come on don't
break my cat he's purring he likes it
sucks do you like that i do
huh
all right tv night with my pro
[Applause]
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is 1 o'clock i have an
owner
he's superman and um
[Music]
like a melody my dog's the best
but he's not the greatest with other
animals this just seems gross we need
gross smelling stuff is one of the
greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs sasha never feed us
chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
but we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumbo in the
back
hey deploy k-9 here what is a k-9
[Music]
shielding that seemed incredibly painful
why can't i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squishy bros
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
500 grand for you guys his guys and for
you
i can't do this without a crew i'll see
what i can do
20 minutes that'll be our window
everybody on the floor
the bank manager is in on it
whatever cash is in the ball it's all
yours
inside you will find this briefcase
people will be looking for that case
cops
we do this right and everyone gets their
share
[Music]
it's done boss we got the case
good
i can get you your case that was stolen
from the bank let me see if i get this
straight you steal from me they steal
from you and now you want to steal back
from them so you can give it to me
i saw an opportunity so i took it
it's the difference between people like
you and people like me
where's my goddamn briefcase
what the hell is this
[ __ ] just got real
[Music]
[Music]
gt actually
i prefer the q4
better turning radius
have a nice day sir
i can't do this goodbye vincent
goodbye then
olivia please don't go out run there's
paparazzi you're being reckless call me
when you're divorced
people are looking i never thought i
would get hit by a podcast
in five days i can't help this getting
out there what if we find the other guy
in the photo and we would pretend to be
a couple i'll do it olivia allen is
gonna go out with me the famous actress
yes the beautiful one yes with me
correct
my sister put you up to this you got me
show time okay ready
say something i'm gonna laugh really
hard i don't understand
are you some kind of sex guy antonio i'm
not a sex dog
[Music]
what's happening here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
antonio this is your first premiere
right
what do you see in my brother he's
decent and kind
i love you i'm famous too which is
surprisingly hard to find
was that your ex i have been trying to
get her back now do the gems maybe we'll
look for what we want out of this
insanity
oh my god when he's here
[Music]
oh god no nothing happened
and i slept in my pants
see
[Applause]
pictures
[Music]
joseph are you coming for easter i don't
know mom i'm really busy i just tested
for this pilot you're going to be a
pilot a network pilot for like a tv show
ah you're playing a pilot on the tv show
no a lawyer you could have been a lawyer
if you only applied yourself
[Music]
a little father and son road trip it's
gonna be fun easter sunday is like the
filipino super bowl there he is there's
mine
welcome home bro see you tonight okay i
just got here you got to follow your
dream and become a beer spokesman that
was my dream let's get the party started
baby and i got to follow mom's stream
and become a nurse
joe vanessa yeah joe valencia you still
driving that same raggedy ass car what
what happened you just gave up huh and
it's your dad you know me and him used
to be real intimate back in the day oh
really yeah i could have been your mama
but clearly i'm not yeah i've literally
never seen this many filipinos in the
same place before
we're sending gifts to our family in the
philippines i'm sending this brand new
hairdryer if it makes your hair look
like that i wouldn't send it how dare
you how dare you we should put them both
in the box and ship it
my mom is at war with my tita theresa
and they don't even know why did you
really have to wear the same dress as my
mom oh i can't help it if i wear it
better this is war oops
family is a mess we're counting on you
to fix it bye
ladies and gentlemen
we're all we got so let's get the party
started baby
moments like these are few and far
between let's enjoy it
filipino families fight a lot make sure
you're not late for dinner but we love a
lot too
your cousin eugene owes me a lot of
money
can you lend it to me no
does he have a death wish deluxe is
legit crazy i once saw him shoot
somebody in a dick what right in the
actual hole in the hole
here we go
where is my money here are my atm cards
my pin number is 12 17. oh also it's
mine
yeah why do you all have the same pin
number it's money
no right the guy who couldn't beat
mayweather
can we go get coffee you can go ahead
and email me pretty much the same just
take the aol off that [ __ ] nessa at
daleycity.com got it
we're going to show you wall flowers the
perks of real flowers
watch out watch out
wayne you're going the wrong way you
want to go cause we can go right now
this message is transmitted at the
request of the united states office of
civil defense we are under siege by a
chemical attack
how bad is it it's
not that bad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
follow the heroes not to zero keep up
we need to find weapons if you get us
killed i'm going to be so pissed
what do you suggest we do i say draw
them to one side of the building and
then slip through the other
i'm a dnd level 20 raw wizard how to
protect us
what is it with you shut-ins and zombie
fantasy we're on the goddamn comic book
okay
whoa watch the dolce
is he dead
of course he's dead ryan he just rolled
the freaking room
what we need
is fire
[Music]
more like badass
[Music]
if anybody knows how to start a party
it's my brother andrew
or should i say
the jig conductor
it's fine it's so cute it's so good no
mom if anybody sees that i'm going to
get put on a watch list
i can't believe college is over you have
a job now we're not allowed to talk
about jobs at the bob mitchell party so
you either don't have a job or you have
a bad job how much does a party starter
get paid i wonder
i have a bad job yeah
honey i'm not just saying this because
i'm your mother i feel like you're way
ahead of the game
[Music]
who's that that's a mom and a kid
do you two dance we're not feeling that
right now how about i bet you 300 i can
get on the dance floor i will give you a
thousand dollars
[Music]
she really likes you i really like her
tonight is the night that you and lola
danced your booties off
oh i don't know how to moonwalk
do you think he would be a good sitter
for you i do not do well with sitters
but i think it might be a bit different
with andrew
do you want to meet my hamster
yeah
i want to thank you for being so kind to
lola easiest thing in the world i'm
having more fun now than i did the whole
[Music]
do you have night husband i have a
fiance i hear you're a great party
starter i hear you're a great
professional lawyer
much to figure out after college
[Music]
giving your heart to somebody is the
most
perplexing thing
you can't just decide that you love
somebody yes you can no you can't yes
you can
we don't need you to babysit anymore why
lots of reasons
are you drunk right now son everything
is just some bits growing up is hard
is he your soulmate do you believe in
soulmates i think we all have a ton of
soul mates how many soul mates for you
like four how many do you have like
twelve hundred
[Music]
i have it i have it i have it focus
right here
[Applause]
all of you wives
[Music]
[Music]
and discretion above all else
boys and their toys at least we know
they're getting work done
[Music]
welcome to the victory project we're all
here because we believe in the mission
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
that's right
what do you think
they're really doing out there
what do you mean
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
[Music]
where it's safe
[Music]
do you even know what the victory
project actually is have you ever asked
do you
please
what's actually happening stop it alice
what if this place is dangerous
no
jack
it's okay
i'm curious to hear where she's going
with this
i need you to listen to
[Music]
me they're lying about everything
we are not going backwards we're pushing
forward
everyone is acting like i'm crazy
i'm not crazy
our life together
i could lose this
i don't trust it
and i don't want to be here
anymore
[Music]
got a pass to underground are you guys
yeah yeah we're just going to go to a
couple parties and it took me
three weeks to ask kissing just to get
into one
good thing
dum
[Music]
[Music]
there's an unconscious white girl in our
living room what
[Music]
[Music]
the cops are not going to listen they
just go come in here and see three brown
guys hanging over this little white girl
we looked everywhere and we can track
her on your phone
we can't just leave her somewhere we
take her to the hospital
[Applause]
i told you we should just call 911
looks like she's in that car what the
hell is going on we don't know who she
is actually she just told me that she's
in high school
[Applause]
think about it statistically
how many people actually get shot by the
cops it's like really really unlikely
right
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
i always just did whatever i wanted
because i was young and i didn't care
you're gonna have to promise me
something
what
she won't call the cops
um hello miss carlisle mrs
ben saunders gardner extraordinaire
ready to get started
hey ben
something i can do for you mrs carla
thank you you know how you could like
really really thank me
mind if i jump in the pool are you a
swimmer i never really get the chance
but i'm pretty good at most physical
stuff
she's a little out of your league don't
you think here's some advice all things
in this world are divided into groups do
not mix your groups
look i don't have anything and i see
your house and your car you have all
these beautiful things and they aren't
being taken care of you have no idea
what it means to a guy like me to take a
dip in a private pool
it's all the game
the whole world
i'd like to report an illegal alien in
my neighborhood
only suckers choose not to play
you like her you want her
you want me to cut her so she bleeds all
over
she makes no difference to me
you want something that doesn't belong
to it
you're kind of overstaying my welcome
maybe you should go do you want me to
[Music]
sophie you're not here yet fathers play
a big role in their daughter's life
it's a special bond that only they share
and even when she's all grown up she's
still
daddy's little girl
[Music]
i have something to say i'm engaged
and i propose wow you performed okay you
proposed yes you proposed to him he
didn't propose to you can you do that
does anyone do that
you both have been coming here for over
a year do you still want this marriage
to work or not
[Music]
i'm here no
[Music]
we're supposed to play the perfect
family until sophie gets married all we
can say sorry to spoil your happiness
but we're getting a divorce muscle tough
mommy happy this is alan castillo we
don't want some big fancy wedding and we
want to pay for it two lawyers are out
of college working for a non-profit is
going to pay for the wedding billy i'm
the father of the bride and i will be
paying for the wedding and i'm going to
be walking my daughter down the aisle
the wedding planner see you in 20
minutes wedding planner
so what are we thinking about theme
cream we don't want a catholic wedding
what are you talking about you're gonna
officiate then my guide monika from the
zen center new york so yoga class is set
up a wedding i caramba
this is my father for the wedding oh my
god oh rick is this guy gonna have some
champagne i've come aboard what is your
bond villain
we should go over the ground rules can
we hold hands we can
can we dance if necessary how about a
kiss absolutely not
[Music]
daddy what is the budget that we're
working with
how about that
yes
i really like him he's nothing like us
maybe that's the point we don't watch
voice no i play sports i like hiking
things have been coming at me very fast
it's time for me to embrace the future i
got your back showtime baby
now with this
[Applause]
[Music]
ready yes and you
no
[Music]
[Music]
hello l.a
first up we've got star girl
hi i'm new to california i usually sing
with a ukulele but here's to trying new
things
i was lying in my room and the news
came on tv
i guess i didn't think we'd be moving
again so quickly i thought you liked
going on adventures a lot of people
going on adventures is one thing but
having your whole life be an adventure
is another but life is an adventure love
and mercy i love you singing thank you
i'm evan i'm star girl cool name what's
going on out here evan she's our new
neighbor hi
[Music]
my brother and i are making this movie
and it's got music in it but we need a
girl for it and you could be the perfect
person
[Music]
so you want to be in our movie all right
let's do it
oh my god that's roxanne martel who she
put out one album and then nothing she's
here every night write your own stuff no
i just really like other people's stuff
you're gonna have to figure out your own
thing
nobody can tell you
[Music]
sing
your special
[Music]
all i wanted was to dream crazy things
and find people crazy enough to dream
them with me you gave me something i
thought only existed in
pictures and i got more than that
[Music]
something i never expected
even nobody else sings alone
that was a keeper let's take a break
[Music]
i thought this summer was going to be
like all the other summers
too bad i like me better without them
one two
three
[Music]
they said i didn't belong
that it was impossible
that would never make it
it is a very special night for the
atanakupo family that we couldn't have
an impact
but we knew together
we couldn't lose
do you hoop
basketball show up play
papa always talks about opportunity
what if this is it
it's okay we go again we fought to get
back up
you feel good you can help mom and dad
when one person in the family scores
the whole family scores
you're illegal immigrants
we can get you all sent back home this
is our home
[Music]
they can knock us down
but they can't stop us from getting back
up
[Applause]
[Music]
you know anything about milwaukee
giannis no sir but
i would love to learn
[Music]
hey
these buddies need to go outside
i knew baby is gonna need your sister
jackie's room to sleep
jackie's in than my animals
it's going to be your comfy new home
if you need help just ask me quackety
duck
welcome to lovely little farm these
animals will grow up just fine out here
oh yeah
if you still brush my tail so it looks
this good
where everyone cares for one another
we're going to be the most caring
sharing big sisters ever big we did it
and small
it's really tricky i could try and help
one hand gently underneath thanks still
glad we've got you farmer jill oh double
glad i've never been happier i love my
little farm
lovely little farm
[Music]
hey intruder whoa
i have pointy ones too look
who are you how did you get a ring my
name is jon stewart and if i told you
you wouldn't believe me
what the hell
at last i found you
jon stewart of earth what you possess
singular will welcome to the green
lantern corps
after years of bloody war the owen's
security net was disabled hal jordan and
millions of thanagarians died that day
they will pay well she's fun
sinestro thrives on chaos and death get
ready for a fight annihilate them
i've been up against that kind of
barrier my whole life
it hasn't stopped me yet
coordinate said
um
let's go
[Music]
you